[Music]
hello everyone welcome to ml news today
I just want to look into one story which
is a hearing in front of the U.S Senate
essentially gives the Senate an
opportunity to interview some people
from the field and to make more informed
decisions invited to the hearing as far
as I can tell where Christina Montgomery
of IBM Gary Marcus professor at NYU and
Sam Altman of openai I want to just
comment on a few things that I think are
worth commenting on I'm working off of
the summary of a machine learning Street
talk I think Tim does an excellent job
doing a broader summary of what happened
and giving some of his comments so
definitely recommend if you go and watch
the mlst video on this one it goes into
a lot more topics than I will go into
here second clearly defining risks there
must be clear guidance on AI uses or
also will not be commenting much on
Christina Montgomery's testimony right
here because coming from IBM it just
corporate speech as as far as I can tell
as this technology advances we
understand that people are anxious about
how it could change the way we live we
are too so I think in Broad here Sam
Altman makes a you know really nice
presentation and his takes are really
smart like he clearly notice he's very
intelligent person and he's quite
optimistic like he manages to convey
that optimism about the future of AI and
the future of this technology and all
and I find this takes for example how
it's going to affect the job market and
how it's going to affect the economy and
all of that I find them to be very
reasonable and very well argued and very
well said here so I want to give
compliments to that I feel it makes a
really good case for the field of AI to
be part of the future and not to make
people that afraid or anything like this
and to make people genuinely excited
about it so I have no troubles with that
compliments to Sam for all of this I do
want to comment on the things obviously
where I disagree but don't take that as
an indication that I disagree with Sam
on All Things again I recommend to watch
the mlst video on this to get more of
his testimony the biggest disagreement
and I think that's for a lot of people
goes when Sam goes into the topic of
potentially licensing AI companies here
is how it sounds like I think that
regulatory intervention by governments
will be critical to mitigate the risks
of increasingly powerful models
for example the U.S government might
consider a combination of Licensing and
testing requirements for development and
release of AI models above a threshold
of capabilities so notably he says the
licensing and testing requirements
should be for models above certain
capabilities and he elaborates later on
that as well new approach any new law
does not stop the Innovation from
happening with smaller companies open
source models researchers that are doing
work at a smaller scale that's a
wonderful part of this ecosystem in of
America we don't want to slow that down
there still may need to be some rules
there but I think we could draw
align at systems that need to be
licensed in a very intense way the
easiest way to do it I'm not sure if
it's the best but the easiest would be
to talk about the amount of compute that
goes into such a model so we could you
know we could Define a threshold of
compute and it'll have to go it'll have
to change it could go up or down I could
down as we discover more efficient
algorithms that says above this amount
of compute you are in this regime
um what I would prefer it's harder to do
but I think more accurate is to Define
some capability thresholds and say a
model that can do things X Y and Z up to
all to decide that's now in this
licensing regime but models that are
less capable you know we don't want to
stop our open source Community we don't
want to stop individual researchers we
don't want to stop new startups can
proceed you know with a different frame
as you can please state which
capabilities you'd propose would
consider for the purposes of this
definition I would love rather than to
do that off the cuff to follow up with
your office with like a well perhaps
openings opine understanding that you're
just responding and you're not making
law all right in the spirit of just
opinion um I think a model that can
persuade manipulate influence a person's
Behavior or a person's beliefs that
would be a good threshold I think a
model that could help create novel
biological agents would be a great
threshold
things like that so I think one thing is
clear from this clip this person knows
what he's talking about which is not the
case with all of the witnesses here in
front of the Senate this clearly comes
from experience and from a technical
expertise in the matter even though Sam
Altman might not be on the Forefront of
actually training these things there is
a clear handle on what actually makes
the capabilities and so on I find the
reasoning of this I find to be sound I
don't think the I disagree but I find
the reasoning of it to be sound in terms
of okay if we regulate something
probably compute is sort of the best
proxy for sort of capabilities and it
would be better to measure capabilities
but we can't yet I mean that all is
reasonable what I have trouble with is
in the first place suggesting this
regulation because essentially saying
you know there should be a line where
you need to be licensed and anything
below is fine because we don't want to
crush the open source ecosystem and so
on you know but then there is a line
essentially that says you know if you
you just do your itty bitty thing in
your garden right and it's small and
it's cute right you know no problem for
us but it's a long-standing element in
the Playbook of big corporations to ask
and to welcome regulatory actions
because imposing regulations imposing
licenses automatically means it makes it
much harder for anyone else to enter
that market so the position is as long
as you're doing your things down here
that's fine but if you really if you
want to come up to our level like if the
open source Community for some reason
actually gets a handle on these things
and threatens open ai's virtual monopoly
now or or Duo Paulina with Google
entering the market then we should you
know clamp down regulatorily and
conforming with regulations is easy if
Microsoft chips billions and billions of
dollars into you like you can handle it
but you very much know that the open
source Community for example cannot
handle it they cannot handle a lawsuit
they cannot handle or easily handle
regulatory compliance we've seen time
and time again that the open source
Community actually manages to reach and
surpass the level of commercial
offerings think of the Linux operating
system which is now powering almost the
entire internet as does the Apache web
server and things like this open source
technology will catch up and that is
exactly the effect that licensing and
testing requirements and all of this
have is to squash that competition and
to make it much much harder for small
businesses and for startups to reach
open ai's level and threaten their
business and the fact that oh there is a
line and the licensing should only apply
above this line it is a bit better in
that it actually lets the open source
Community do some things at their level
but it has the same effects right
because ultimately we engage in open
source we engage in research we engage
in competition too displace the market
leader because there is going to be an
improved offering this there's going to
be a more transparent of offering in the
future and in all cases that regulation
denies that or makes it much harder and
I find it to be quite disturbing that
Sam Altman here asks for this while
couching it in sort of the language of
oh it's all safety related but oh the
open source Community is so important
like no you profit highly highly from
the fact that open source software in
the past not only has reached the
capabilities of commercial offerings but
vastly surpassed them without any
regulatory oversight is there an FDA for
Linux no there isn't right the source
code is open you can see what's in there
and that is much more of a safety
guarantee and a guarantee of you
understand what's going on than any
other thing and yes I get it with neural
networks it's not like source code where
I can read it and flat out sort of make
a test for it but within large enough
software systems that's the case too
like Linux and I think if we were to
publish what data went into these big
models how how exactly they were trained
if we were to publish their weights then
we would have insane amounts of
knowledge of you know what's possible
what's not possible and how to deploy
them safely but that's exactly what
openai doesn't want to do there are more
and more secretive about exactly what's
in their model and that's the other part
there are some people still agreeing
with Sam Altman here and saying well
what if they really believe these things
are dangerous you know doesn't this make
sense right to have the agencies and so
on and I'll show you a second clip here
labor should we consider independent
testing labs
to provide scorecards and nutrition
labels or the equivalent of nutrition
labels packaging that indicates to
people whether or not
the content can be trusted what the
ingredients are so the question is
should there be nutrition labels that
tell people what's in these models
listen to Sam's answer right here that
people users are pretty sophisticated
and understand where the mistakes are
that they need or likely to be that they
need to be responsible for verifying
what the models say that they go off and
check it
um
I I worry that as the models get better
and better uh the users can have sort of
less and less of their own
discriminating thought process around it
but but I think users are more capable
than we could often give them credit for
in in conversations like this I think a
lot of disclosures which if you've used
chat gbt you'll see about the
inaccuracies of the model
um are also important and I'm I'm
excited for a world where companies
publish with the models information
about how they behave where the
inaccuracies are and independent
agencies or companies provide that as
well I think it's a great idea Sam
directs the conversation into again the
realm of capabilities and where the
inaccuracies are and what the models are
capable of but a really easy thing to
say which Gary Marcus repeats sometimes
in this hearing is how about you just
publish the data that went into it how
about you just publish how you trained
it how long it was trained and so on
open AI notoriously no gloriously and
with Glee as far as I can tell denied to
give the research Community any of that
data in their latest technical report
purposefully hiding it like it was very
common until that point too say here's
our model this is the size here is what
it was trained on here is how it was
trained here is the loss here is how it
behaves and so on on different things
and openai has anything but that last
category where they demonstrated they
can take a bar test and pass it anything
other than that they have deliberately
obscured so they have deliberately went
completely against that idea of a
nutrition label hey let's tell people
what's inside so they can make an
informed decision and so that they can
deploy these things safely so if someone
was really first of all as he says you
know give the users more credit because
they should be able to make their own
decisions using this technology and if
you actually thought it was a good idea
to do these nutrition labels it'd be
very much for you know publishing all of
the ingredients right here and an
effective regulation could be that once
you deploy I don't know a model you have
to disclose in some way what's inside
I'm not per se for that but rather than
whatever is proposed right here just
saying you have to disclose the dates or
you have to publish the weights I don't
know we have to make it economically
viable but um clearly directs the
conversation away from that and back
into the regime of woo capabilities and
yeah so combined with the sayings before
we need some kind of Licensing and
testing above a certain threshold and we
will deliberately not tell you what's
inside there is I don't think that combo
makes a lot of sense and I don't think
that's a coherent line except under the
aspect of hey let's make sure we have
some business tomorrow and let's make
sure we make it as hard as possible for
others to threaten that business lastly
I want to make a comment on the
statements made by Gary Marcus here I
legitimately don't know why Gary Marcus
is in this hearing but yes so good for
him I guess
um but here is how that goes from the
inherent unreliability of current
systems a law professor for example was
accused by a chatbot of sexual
harassment untrue and it pointed to a
Washington Post article that didn't even
exist
the more that that happens the more that
anybody can deny anything as one
prominent lawyer told me on Friday
defendants are starting to claim that
plaintiffs are making up legitimate
evidence these sorts of allegations
undermine the abilities of juries to
decide what or who to believe can
contribute to the undermining of
democracy
no way are you saying stuff that's
written isn't always true that is I I
I'm con okay forget everything I said
like that convinces me because I mean so
far before we had gpt4 and all of these
things everything that was written was
true like any allegation you know any
person claiming that something was in a
news article or there was some study
proving something was certainly correct
in doing so every allocation made by
defendants about evidence like no one
has ever lied in a court or made up
stuff or made up evidence this is it's a
new world man and we I I'm convinced
like you know these things can make
false statements that just wasn't
possible before I I tried using this
technology called email once I wanted to
to scam someone I wanted to persuade
someone of something but it just
wouldn't let me but this is the
statement it can make up stuff like
what what kind of a bar is this for no
other technology in the world has been
held to the standards of it can make up
stuff therefore it's bad or it can be
used to make up stuff a keyboard can be
used to make up stuff I can find tons of
made-up stuff on Google I can generate
tons of made up stuff using Photoshop
actually Sam Altman has a take on that
as well if you can find it in this
testimony where he says and I find that
to be very reasonable where he says look
the world has seen Photoshop and for a
while Photoshop has fooled some people
but then very quickly people realized oh
hey not everything that's a picture is
you know real and he says well this is
the same but on steroids but you know
we've had to deal for a long time with
texts may not be true so I failed to see
that just because it becomes a bit
cheaper to hire you know gpt4 rather
than I don't know some labor form in a
low wage tree like yes it's a bit
cheaper to write false things at scale I
don't see how that fundamentally changes
how we think about these things and I
get tons of email each day asking me for
some sort of money and I'm perfectly
fine perfectly fine even though you know
according to Gary Marcus also these
systems they are you know have lacks so
far they're not as good as humans yet so
the humans trying to convince me but
send me these emails they should be
smarter than that right and so far they
haven't managed yet like I only ever
sent money to legitimate uncles who died
and I had to pay the lawyers fees then
there was a problem and I never got them
but it was totally fine so that was my
take on these things again Watch Tim's
video it's really cool it's about 50
minutes long and you'll get the most
important parts of that hearing bye
[Music]
thank you